before sal started working here he was a
stock broker and we always are
marveling at the fact that he was
handling other people's money and
advising them
and we said you know sal honestly none
of us believe you have any ability in
fact if we put you up
in stock picking against wendy's i think
wendy's got a good shot at beating you
and he's like oh no
i know what i'm doing i was really good
as a stock broker
i had some games you're really gonna
pick stock we gave a list of stocks
and they chose from the following stocks
amazon netflix
domino's pizza target gamestop disney
pepsi walmart
wendy's apple and mcdonald's and wendy
and sal
alternated turns okay here they are
making their first picks we were pretty
excited about this here we go
what will be your number one draft pick
disney world
so sal what do you think of wendy's
first pick of disney world
well wendy i love you but that was a
horrible pick
horrible there's a pandemic
[ __ ] i do know that there's a pandemic
going on and nobody in their right mind
would be going to an amusement park
filled with people
there are people going into this thing
real stupid
sal what is your first pick my first
pick wolfie
will be amazon i choose amazon
because whether there's a pandemic or
not it's a proven company
with phenomenal sales consistent growth
and a proven chart record wendy do you
think sal taking amazon was a wise pick
uh no because he's stupid
right this is thrilling i i honestly
during this
when i first heard i felt like i was on
the floor of the new york stock exchange
it was so awesome
wendy and sal made their second
selection robin listen carefully wendy
what will be your number two pick
my number two pick will be pepsi
because i drink uh mountain dew and
pepsi
does pepsi manufacturer mountain dew
yeah
yep i think it's a an okay selection
in my opinion it's a slow mover but
short term you made a big mistake wendy
oh shut up
[ __ ] shut the [ __ ] up you douchebag
sell which stock will you choose with
your second pick that pick will be
netflix a lot of people are at home um
a lot of movies now are being released
directly
on netflix ah shut up you don't know
jack [ __ ] style you're a douchebag
loser sal doesn't know what
a stock is explain to sal what stock is
wendy
stock is a copy where you
do a lot of this
what was that wendy doc is where you do
a lot of business
i actually like wendy's thoughts here
because
the pepsi company owns a whole bunch of
brands you know they diversified
they did very well during the pandemic
while strictly beverage companies did
not
i don't mean to talk about your personal
finances but robin just
invested a half a million dollars with
wendy as a stockbroker
that's how that's how committed she is
that's right i'm letting her manage my
money
that's right all right then we asked
wendy for her third pick here we go
walmart walmart is a heavy hitter wendy
why did you decide
to take walmart because i shop at
walmart
sal what do you think of that choice i'm
impressed with that pick wendy i have to
give you a little credit there
walmart's a good company it won't be
enough to beat me
jackass you don't know a damn thing
walmart is off the board who will you
choose with your next pick
i'm gonna go head to head with wendy i'm
going to pick a retail consumer as well
that i think will do
better than walmart i'm going with
target i'll
shop at target because target's too
expensive
he doesn't know the hell he's doing
i would say those two picks are awash
target and walmart
there was some confusion when wendy saw
the apple logo on the board listen
in wendy which company will you select
with your last
pick i'll select applebee's all right so
wendy just so you know
this is apple computers not applebee's
the restaurant
please confirm are you taking apple
computers
off the board um i'll uh
i'll choose wendy's wendy why did you
choose
wendy's the restaurant because i love
their dave single
and they're chilly what's your last pick
sal
i'm gonna take a big risk here and
without risk there is not reward i'm
going to add gamestop to my portfolio
wendy what do you think about that sal
chooses gamestop last
uh good luck douchebag sounds
a loser well how will you feel when this
loser beats
you wouldn't that make you a bigger
loser uh
no that'll make me the winner and
you the douchebag loser that cannot get
any [ __ ] oh wow there's a lot of trash
talk in this one yeah
i didn't know wendy was so good at trash
talk wendy had some really harsh parting
words for sal she's taking this very
seriously wendy you're sitting there
with your
arms crossed looking super confident why
are you feeling so confident
because sal doesn't know jack crap
wendy i say good luck you're going to
need it
i'll go with your ass douchebag so take
that
we're going to continue to track their
stock portfolios over the next three
months
yes so of course uh stay tuned